meghan trainor gushed over boyfriend and  spy kids star darryl samara at CBS  radio's we can't survive concert  Saturday night the me to singer only  told ET how the two lovebirds met  through our friend Chloe Chloe grace  Moretz told me she had a really really  nice friends and I was like that's crazy  I'm looking for a really really nice guy  and he's just like you guys have to meet  and we did it mate earlier this month  Meghan confirm rumors that the couple  was an item with this sweet shot via  Instagram captioned I loved Madrid and  this guy Daryl has been on the road with  trainer for her untouchable tour and  Meghan told et all about the best date  they've been on so far we've traveled  the world together already in just a  short amount of time the best date man  we recently went to Spain went to Madrid  for a few shows so I guess spending time  in Madrid was pretty special  you